Starting today, we arre having a 10% off
Back-To-School sale over at microcosmos.store.
So whether you are decorating a new dorm room
or classroom, or you’re just trying to
decide what to wear for your first day of
school, microcosmos.store has you covered.
We’ve got t-shirts,
sweatshirts, pins, and posters.
And we’ve got our Microcosmos
microscope, slides and coverslips,
and even a Microcosmos microfiber cloth
to keep everything nice and clean.
And this week only, from now through August
8th, almost everything in the store is 10% off!
And that’s not all, we’ve also got this
new Dark Mode version of our Hydra t-shirt
that's only going to be available
during this sale and then never again.
So, head over to Microcosmos.store
to check out the sale and to pick
up your limited edition Dark Mode Hydra T-Shirt
This channel would not be what it is if it weren’t
for one very key invention: the microscope.
Everything we see, we see with the aid
of light and lenses, expertly deployed
by our master of microscopes, James.
And if you’ve been on this journey from
the beginning, or if you’ve ever gone back to
revisit our earlier videos, you may have noticed
that things have changed a bit around here.
Everything we can see is a function of the tools
we use. And as we’ve explored new microscopes
along with other new tools and techniques,
that means we’ve been able to see the microcosmos
differently. Colors have changed, contrast has
deepened, and sometimes things even sparkle.
So today, we’re tracking our journey… through
our journey. We have compiled the videos we’ve
made that focus on how our microscopes work
and the ways we have improved our methods over time
so you can see how much of microscopy is an art—an
art that uses light in incredible
ways that only physics could predict.
So to start, let’s go back to an
early video, where we went through
the different methods we used at the start of
our channel to illuminate our samples. Think
of it like an introduction to optics, told
through the bodies of tardigrades and algae.
This is a ciliate, just a eukaryotic microbe
waving its cilia around under our microscope.
This is the same ciliate.
And yup, here it is again…
…and again.
But as you’re probably noticing,
while the rough outline of this organism
seems the same from shot to shot,
the ciliate itself and the world around it clearly
look very different from shot to shot. Colors
change, details are more apparent. In one
case the organism seems lit from within.
On this channel, we're constantly flipping between
different ways of capturing images of organisms.
So which one of them is what they
actually look like? Well...none of them.
Anything you see through a microscope is an image
—which in our case, means that everything we
show you on this channel, every frame,
is not the microbial world itself.
It’s an interpretation of life on the other
side of our objective, translated through the
lens into details, shapes, and colors—all affected
by the way we light up the life we want to see.
Light is amazing, it’s also very weird.
It travels in waves, and as it interacts with
particles and materials, it scatters, shifts. Even
if we can’t actually see those light waves in motion,
so much of what we observe in the world
around us is rooted in the physical properties
that define those waves—like how we can observe
certain frequencies of light as colors. But waves
have far more to them than
just their frequency, and microscopy
has combined the resourcefulness of many
different sciences to use light to give us
different ways to peer into the microbial world.
So let’s start simple with the good old fashioned
white light. Early microscopists used oil lamps
and sunlight to see through their microscopes,
and while the technology has changed, the
simplicity of this has endured into
the modern technique of brightfield microscopy.
It all starts with a source of light, though
modern microscopes have their lamps built in, set
up underneath the stage that holds our sample.
Light travels from the source through
a condenser, which works to focus
the light onto the sample above it.
This focused light travels through the
sample towards the objective lens, which takes
in an image and magnifies it into these bright
backgrounds with organisms, sometimes rendered
transparent by the intensity of the light.
You might say that this is as close as we get
to seeing what the microcosmos actually looks like,
but that would be like taking 2000 watt
light bulb into your living room and saying,
“this is what my home looks like.” Light affects
things, and we are not shining light on these
organisms, we’re shining light through them.
Now, brightfield might seem relatively simple,
but that simplicity has been incredibly powerful
in allowing scientists old and new to wade through
microscopic waters. Still, there are limitations
to consider with any scientific technique,
and one of the major challenges for
brightfield microscopy, particularly
when we’re looking at microbes, is contrast.
Pigmented organisms are easy to visualize against
the bright background, but in cases where
the organism has been rendered transparent,
it can be harder to distinguish their bodies
from the rest of the world they inhabit.
Scientists can navigate these challenges using
stains that make certain structures more visible,
but for our purposes, we like to avoid stains
because they can affect the microbes themselves.
There are ways to contend with this challenge,
one of which is built on one of those
simple-yet-strange properties of our world:
you don’t always need to shine light directly
onto an object to see it. This technique is called
darkfield microscopy, which sounds like it
must be the opposite of brightfield microscopy.
It’s not. The two techniques
are actually very similar:
light travels from a source through a condenser,
interacts with the sample, and then travels into
the objective lens, producing the image we see.
But what we want in darkfield microscopy is for the
beam of light to hit the sample, but not our eye.
In darkfield microscopy, a circular
disk is placed inside the condenser,
blocking the central part of the light light from
shining through the sample and into our eye, or,
our camera. This means that when there is no
sample on the slide, all you’ll see is black.
But the disk doesn’t block all light: there
is still a hollow cone of light that travels
around the disk, unable to reach the objective or
our eyes, but that light still hits the sample.
When it does, their microscopic, transparent
bodies scatter those hidden rays intoour
view. And as they do, an image of their
bodies forms against a dark background,
providing us with this almost cinematic footage.
Another method to get better contrast than
brightfield microscopy is called
phase contrast microscopy,
and it’s built on working with a property of
light that we can’t actually directly experience.
Microbes , or really anything, that is easily
visually observed with brightfield microscopy
are called amplitude objects because
as light passes through them,
the amplitude of the light wave changes,
which we see as changes in light intensity.
But there is another class of specimens: these
are called phase objects. As light passes through
these objects, the waves slow down and shift
slightly in phase compared to the unaffected light
around it. And if you’re wondering what that means
in terms of what we can see, that’s the issue:
our eyes don’t process these differences
in phase. And so in the final image,
these objects, or in our case,
organisms, are very difficult to see.
In the 1930s, a physicist named Frits Zernike
developed a method to shift the direct
light just slightly enough so that these
changes in phase could actually be translated
into changes in amplitude, producing
an image of these formerly hard-to-see
phase objects by essentially treating them
as amplitude objects. There is a lot of
physics to this that we are glossing
over, but the result was so important
that it would eventually win Zernike the
Nobel Prize in Physics. And of course,
selfishly, we appreciate his work because it lets
us see more of our more hidden microbial friends.
And for the last type of microscopy we’ll go over
today, we’re going to be getting into another
property of light that we can’t directly
see, but that makes the microcosmos glow.
Most of the light we see has an electrical field
that vibrates in all sorts of planes relative to
the direction the light is traveling in. But
that vibration can be restricted to one plane,
and when that happens, the light is said to
be polarized. We[8] can’t see the difference
between polarized and unpolarized light.
You might notice the difference in how the
world looks when you’re wearing polarized
sunglasses, but these are changes brought
about by changes in color or intensity,
not the polarization of the light itself.
So when does polarized light help us
in microscopy? Well, a lot of materials
stay the same optically-speaking, no matter what
direction you shoot light at them with. But there
are certain materials where specific properties,
like how fast light travels through them, can vary
depending on which way the light is striking them.
These materials. called optically anisotropic,
can also take in a ray of light and
divide it into two separate beams.
By aiming polarized light at our sample
and then reconstructing an image based on
how the various parts of the organism
interacts with that restricted light,
particularly by how it might cause the light
to split, we can see more of these optically
anisotropic materials in action. In our case,
it often takes the form of shiny crystals.
So we’ve given you the big overview of
what these different techniques can do,
let’s go back and review what that means
for the original ciliate we started with.
This is the ciliate under brightfield microscopy.
The background is bright, the image produced by
changes in light amplitude that allow us to see
the overall shape. But some of the detail is hard
to make out. Under darkfield though, the contrast
increases and some of these details become more
obvious, displaying compartments and cilia in
greater detail that are also apparent under
phase contrast. And then under polarized light,
the crystals that blended in with the organism
previously are now quite visible and vibrant.
There are, of course, many other microscopy
techniques, but we think it’s incredible that
with just these four, the world of the microcosmos
looks almost like different universes,
wrapped up in one invisible world
around us. The journey, it seems, is not
just about what you see, but how you see it.
And ultimately, none of these views are
what the microcosmos actually looks like,
either that, or all of them are. Our brains play
tricks on us to make us believe that the world
looks one way, but the world looks different
at night than in the day, and both of those
things have more to do with the physiology
of our eyes than their objective reality.
Asking what microbes look like is, to
some extent, forcing our own experience
onto something that is beyond it. Which is
not something I ever would have thought of
if it weren’t for this little YouTube channel.
Now we have been really fortunate over the years
to have the support of so many people,
and to be able to direct that support
back to the microscopes we use.
In 2020, we introduced James’ new microscope,
which he was able to buy thanks to crowdfunding.
This was our first major microscope upgrade on
the series, and it’s incredible to see the jump
in quality and how it compares to the different
techniques we showcased in the previous video.
This golden algae is swimming around
in water and white light, illuminated
from below using a brightfield microscope.
And here we have that mallomonas sample,
filmed a day later using a different
technique thanks to a brand new,
freshly installed microscope.
When James, our master of microscopes,
saw them for the first time, he got a little
emotional because, to quote him directly,
“the thing I know so well, was looking
so so much different than usual.”
Those differences in how the mallomonas look are
due to a type of microscopy called “Differential
Interference Contrast.” Or…DIC.
Earlier this year, James started
a crowdfunding campaign to purchase a
new microscope, one that would allow him
to use differential interference contrast
to produce these images you are seeing now.
Now technically, “differential interference
contrast” is not a type of microscope. Rather,
it’s a method that enhances contrast. And as you
can see, the final product is an image that seems
almost 3-dimensional. Just watch this stentor
coeruleus as it swims across the slide. Its
cilia are so prominent that
it almost feels like you can
touch their vibrating fuzziness. And
the striations down its body are so
sharp that when the stentor contracts, it’s
like you can feel it pushing inward and then
back out again. I don’t know about you,
but it’s almost like you could reach out
and touch it—like you’re in a movie theater
with 3d glasses on, reaching out to something
that seems to be reaching back out to you.
Differential interference contrast microscopy
was invented by Georges Nomarski in 1952,
building off the principles underlying phase
contrast microscopy, which is a different though
similar thing. But both of these methods work
to translate invisible shifts in light phase that
can happen when studying certain samples into
visible changes in light amplitude, which we see
as changes in light intensity. And as a result,
both techniques enhance contrast and let us see
parts of the microcosmos that might be invisible
with regular brightfield microscopy. But phase
contrast microscopy and DIC shift and work with
light in different ways to accomplish this goal.
How do they do it? Well, if you’ve ever taken an
optics course, you will remember how terrible
that was. But, very basically, phase contrast
and DIC are two ways to take advantage of
a strange reality. Light actually travels
further through some materials than others. Kinda.
The optical path length is a function of both
the distance between two points and the refractive
index of the material the light is travelling
through. Basically, denser samples have longer
optical path lengths. Phase contrast microscopy
takes advantage of that, making areas with
longer optical path lengths look darker.
DIC on the other hand, doesn’t make areas
that are denser darker, it uses some very
cool optics to create sharp contrast in areas
of rapid change in the optical path length.
So, the faster the gradient from more to less
dense or vice versa, the more contrast you see.
But it’s also important to note that
while these images are the result of light
traveling through a sample, they are not
an actual topographical map of an organism.
DIC microscopy is a technique, but it does require
certain physical additions to a microscope. For
one thing, we need to split light apart. So,
first we have a prism that splits polarized
light into two orthogonal rays of light that will
then pass through the sample and interact with it
in different ways. And then there’s a second
prism that recombines those two rays after
they’ve traveled through the sample, forming an
image based on the differences those two beams of
light experienced for our eyes and cameras to see.
In addition to these prisms, this technique relies
on having higher quality objectives than what
we’ve been using in the past. The objectives are
the little lenses at the bottom of the microscope
that actually do most of the magnification. Not
many people would realize this, but the objectives
we use for Journey to the Microcosmos are some of
the cheapest and most common types of objectives,
they’re known as achromatic objectives. But while
these objectives produce so many of our favorite
images, James needed a microscope update to be
able to do differential interference contrast.
So with help, perhaps including some from you,
James bought a new Zeiss microscope. It took eight
weeks for it to arrive, which is a long time to
wait. But luckily the manufacturers sent him a 150
page manual to occupy his time until it arrived.
When the microscope finally showed up, James still
had to wait for an engineer to install the nearly
50 pound machine. But he didn’t waste any time.
James went out to gather his precious Mallomonas
and prepared a slide that night, keeping it stored
in a humidity chamber so that he could look at it
as soon as the microscope was ready.
The next day, the Zeiss engineer took
3.5 hours to put all the pieces together
and set everything up. But from there,
well, it was all on James to observe what he
could and experiment with his new microscope.
Some of his experimenting has been geared towards
making sure that he can get the best image
possible. These objectives have a much smaller
working distance compared to our previous ones,
and so you need to prepare the slides
a lot thinner to get a sharper image.
So even for our master of microscopes,
there was somewhat of a learning curve
to make sure he was getting videos that
were as sharp and vivid as he wanted.
But some of the experimenting is
based out of that most exciting thing
of all: curiosity. He’s removed some of the
prisms to see how it affects the footage,
and added a magnifying glass over the light
source to scatter the light in different ways.
That’s the joy of the microcosmos. It is so
infinite. There’s it’s own objective existence,
full of so many more organisms than
we’ll ever be able to identify.
But there’s also the infinite
nature of how we experience it,
of how our own view of this world is shaped by
the many different tools we use to observe it.
And maybe that’s the case all
the time...that what we see
is as much about how we view the world as it is
about the world itself. The same thing with a
different lens, a different technique, a different
base of knowledge, can look completely different.
As we start our third season of
Journey to the Microcosmos, we hope
you will continue to join us through
both our new and old lenses,
as we uncover more of this hidden, unending world.
In 2021, James went all out on improving his
toolkit, investing in higher quality objectives,
a polarizer, and the equipment he needed to do
fluorescence microscopy. If you’re not sure why
those things had all of us on the Journey
to the Microcosmos team so excited, well,
that’s what our next video is for. You will get to
see just how much of a difference an objective
can make, and why electrons jumping up and down
can reveal a whole new side to the microcosmos.
We’re nearing the end of our fourth season of
Journey to the Microcosmos, and over that time,
we’ve been able to see microbes through
all kinds of lenses—literally—thanks
to James, our master of microscopes. For
the rest of us on the Microcosmos team,
it’s been really cool to not only see
the footage that James has recorded,
but also see the journey that he has
been on with the microscopes themselves.
Now, we’ve been able to make this journey
because of all of you and the support you
have shown to this channel by watching and
commenting and sharing with others, or even
and especially by supporting us on Patreon.
We’ve all been on this journey together, so
let’s look back on where it’s taken us, and also
get a peek at where we’re going in the future.
In the first season, James started out with
two microscopes. One was a microscope that
he assembled himself from different parts for
under $200. The other microscope was a Motic
BA310 that he received from a microscope
company shortly after we started this channel.
And these microscopes give us so much beautiful
footage, thanks in part to the different
techniques that James used with them, whether that
was bright-field or phase contrast or darkfield,
or some other technique to manipulate
the light shining on the microcosmos.
But these microscopes also had their
limits, so we were really excited to see
what would happen when James bought a new
microscope before the start of our third season:
the Zeiss Axioscope 5. This new microscope
came with higher quality objectives (which
are the lenses on the bottom of the
microscope), as well as prisms that
made it possible for us to look at microbes with
differential interference contrast microscopy,
a technique that sharpened their features and made
them seem more three-dimensional on our screen.
We have videos exploring these different
techniques and microscopes, so if you want to
learn more about them, we recommend checking those
out because light is much weirder than it seems.
But we wanted to do a quick summary for reasons
that are probably very clear from the title
of this video: we have upgraded our microscope!
The Zeiss Axioscope 5 was a very exciting change,
but it was also an expensive one. So when James
bought it, he was only able to get two objectives:
a 20x objective and a 63x objective. Adding that
to the 10x magnification the eyepiece gives,
let us magnify our samples by 200x and 630x
respectively, which is not bad. But a standard
microscope usually comes with 5-6 objectives for
a reason: the microcosmos is full of things both
small and large to observe and there
isn’t a one-size-fits-all objective
that you can use to observe everything.
So one of James’ priorities was expanding
his set of objectives so that he could have
the flexibility to see the microcosmos at more
scales. And thanks to his recent upgrade,
he’s now gone from a set of 2 to a set of
six that range from 5x to 100x and that gives
us a magnification range from 50x to 1000x.
Since I have gotten my own prototype
of the microcosmos microscope that
we are manufacturing thanks to backers of our
kickstarter, I’ve been amazed at how important
it is to have this variety of options, and how
much time I spend on the lower magnifications
and well as going deeper .
So without further ado,
let’s introduce these different objectives by
looking at a ciliate called Tetrahymena that’s
taken up residence in a rotifer exoskeleton.
With the 5x objective, we can see
little dots swimming in what used to be empty
space, but it’s hard to make out the details.
When we move to the 10x objective, we can
start to make out shapes of the Tetrahymena
and more of the emptiness around them,
but it’s difficult to see the exoskeleton.
Then as we start to go up in magnification,
the details of the exoskeleton become clearer.
It's cool to see more and more of those details
as we zoom in. And especially when we get to
the 100x objective, which gives us 1000x
magnification, you can make out so much of
the insides of the Tetrahymena, that they
look like bags of very resilient bubbles.
Here’s another ciliate called a Pseudoprorodon
that James looked at through all of these
objectives. At first it just looks like a little
green thing floating around and knocking into
stuff. But as we go up in magnification, we can
start to make out the subtle undulations of its
body, which shifts the different shades of green.
And as we look even closer, the green itself takes
on a new life, revealing the perimeters of the
individual algae inside the pseudoprorodon.
Revealing those details inside the tetrahymena
and pseudoprorodon comes at a cost. We can’t
see as much of the world around them,
whether that’s the emptiness around the
rotifer exoskeleton or the objects that
the pseudoprorodon keeps bumping into.
Whether or not you need those details depends on
what you’re trying to learn or what we are trying
to show, and that’s why having the flexibility
to look through a wider range of objectives
is such an exciting upgrade for us. Objectives are
our gateways to the microcosmos, and we’re excited
to have all of these new scales to look at.
We’ve also made some other upgrades so we can
revisit techniques we used on our older
microscopes. Like a polarizer, because
who doesn’t love this shiny, iridescent stuff?
But we’re not just sticking with what we’ve
known. Thanks to this upgrade, we’ve got a
whole new way to look at cells: fluorescence
microscopy. And we are so excited for this one.
The techniques we’ve highlighted so far
are all clever manipulations of white light, a
mixture of many visible wavelengths of light. But
in fluorescence microscopy, instead of
illuminating our sample with that mixture,
we choose a specific wavelength of light.
That light is called the excitation light
because, well, it excites certain
structures based on their chemistry.
And those excitable structures then emit some
light of their own. The emission light will
then travel back through the objective, get past
barriers that filter out the excitation light,
and then show up in our eyes as vivid color.
With our upgrade, we have four different
wavelengths of light that we can
use for fluorescence microscopy,
and the parts of the sample that we see
fluoresce will depend on which light we use.
In this footage, we’re looking at the
Pseudoprorodon that we saw earlier, only
this time it’s being hit with 385 nanometer light.
The red we see is the fluorescence from natural
structures, this is called autofluorescence.
The rest of the organism is dark because
it did not respond to that 385 nanometer
light, making the color all the more vibrant.
But the power of fluorescence microscopy is
not just finding fluorescent structures that
exist in nature. Chemists and biologists
have developed all sorts of ingenious
techniques to highlight different parts of
cells using fluorescent dyes and proteins.
James is working on building up his arsenal of
fluorescence microscopy tools and techniques
so that soon, we’ll be able to dive even deeper
into the microcosmos to seek out things that have
been hidden from us before, uncovering the unseen
world inside the unseen world that surrounds us
The upgrades we’ve talked about in
the last few videos have involved
fancy equipment and exciting techniques. But light
is so weird and powerful that sometimes you don’t
need anything particularly fancy to make it do
something useful. Sometimes you just need
the right objective and a little bit of oil.
If you’ve been following along with us lately,
you probably know that we’re pretty excited
about our latest microscope upgrades. And can
you blame us? It's like having a new toy that’s
actually a spaceship. It’s pretty hard to
shut up about something that is shiny and new,
and also takes you into a whole new world.
And that’s kind of what it feels like to see
our familiar friends at this magnification. Even
though we’ve seen tardigrades many times before,
in so many different ways, we
have not seen them like this.
And bringing this level of magnification gives
us a new layer of the microcosmos to explore.
It’s like we’ve descended into a new level of
a cave, getting further from our world—though
fortunately for the easily scared among
us, the cave is metaphorical and the risks
are negligible. All we need for the journey are
some objective lenses and a tiny drop of... oil?
Yeah, oil.
But to explain
what that oil does, we’re going to have to
get a little technical first. Because yes,
we love our microbes, but we’re only able
to see them thanks to light, and light
is complicated, but we need to give it its due.
So let’s start with the objective lens.
The main job of the objective lens
is to take light leaving the sample
and focus it into an image for the us
to see. And there are two main numbers
that describe the objective lens. The first one’s
pretty obvious: it’s the magnification. But the
magnification you see written on the objective
lens is not the same as the magnification we
write up on the corner of the videos.
That’s because the objective lens isn’t
the only source of magnification in our
microscope. We’re also looking through an
eyepiece that has its own magnification. So the
final magnification that we see is the product of
the objective lens’ and eyepiece’s magnifications.
Now we don’t usually do math on this channel,
but this is one of the rare cases where
the math and optics is straightforward.
In our microscope, the eyepiece has a
magnification of 10x. So if we’re looking through
a 63x objective, the final magnification is 630x.
And that is the number you’ll see in the corner.
But you should never trust an optics lesson that
seems simple. How could it be when the image we’re
seeing is the product of so many things at once,
some tangible like a lens, others much less so.
And what is less tangible than
light, which is, as we’ve seen before
on this channel--a very strange thing. We
cannot touch it, but we can manipulate it,
using what we know of the way it travels and
bends and reflects to see our world differently.
But light… has its limits. The thing about
making things larger is that at some point,
it’s not enough to just zoom in. You need to
be able to capture the detail that’s there.
And this leads to the second important
number you’ll find on an objective lens:
the numerical aperture. Unlike magnification,
“numerical aperture” is probably not super
self-explanatory. What the number describes is
the ability of the objective to take in light.
As light travels from the sample and to
the objective, it radiates outwards like
a cone. The higher your numerical aperture, the
wider the cone of light that's going into your
objective. And that allows for more rays to enter
the objective from all sorts of different angles,
helping to illuminate more details and give
greater resolution to your final image.
But of course, that’s still not all that goes
into capturing the perfect microscopic image.
Let’s take a look at this glaucoma spinning around
at 1000x magnification. It’s visible, and you can
see some of the details. It looks…fine.
But let’s take a look at it again here.
Same glaucoma. Same objective. Same level
of magnification. What was “fine” before
now just looks dull in comparison to the image we
were seeing before with the detailed striations
and vivid pockets of green on the glaucoma’s body.
To get from one of these images to the other,
James—our master of microscopes—didn’t change
any of the technical settings on his microscope
or pull some kind of video editing wizardry. He
just simply added a drop of oil to the coverslip
encasing the glaucoma, and dipped
the objective into the oil.
Now this is because the cone of light going from
the specimen into the objective isn’t just going
straight from the sample to the lens. It’s passing
through something—it’s passing through air.
Light travels at different speeds through
different materials and when it changes
from material to material, it will bend. This
is called refraction and materials like oil
slow light down more.
And that matters to our microscope
because it gives us the wider cones of light
we need to get a higher numerical aperture.
Whether we’ve got air between the sample and
the lens or oil when we’re viewing our samples
depends on the objective we’re looking through.
Our lower magnification objectives have
lower numerical apertures, and they’re meant
to be used with air. Our higher magnification
objectives have higher numerical apertures,
and they’re meant to be used with oil.
Using air with oil objectives gives us poor
images, and using oil with our dry objective
would damage the objective. So…don’t do that.
The numerical aperture and its relationship to
resolution is important because it puts a limit
on just how much magnification we can actually do
with a given objective. There’s a general estimate
if you are looking into microscopy yourself,
that you’ll get a good magnification when you’re
working in the range that’s 500 to 1000 times
the numerical aperture of the objective.
So our 100x objective and 1.3 numerical aperture
can reach a maximum of 1300x magnification
depending on your eyepiece. With our 10x eyepiece,
we get 1000x magnification, and it works great.
But if we tried to get more from this set-up by
increasing the magnification of our eyepiece
to 20x, we could not actually get 2000x
magnification. Because of the constraints
of our numerical aperture, we would just
be losing half of our image without actually
gaining more detail in what’s left to see.
But that’s what happens any time we want to
take an image: we have to make a decision
between what we can and cannot see. There are
always choices that have to be made, and details
that have to be lost. We simply cannot see all
of the world, in all its entirety, all at once.
But we can see more of it by tracking the choices
we make as we dive deeper, choices in techniques
and materials that affect what we can see and
how we see it, and enrich the story further,
even when those choices impose constraints.
At some point in history, we wanted to see more,
and lenses with their magnificent manipulation of
light have helped us do that. We’ve used them to
see light from distant stars, and to peer into the
most mundane surroundings on earth. And whatever
image has come back to us has brought the universe
closer to view, even if it’s just in fractions.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And remember, if you’re watching this before
August 8th, you have until then to check out
our back to school sale at microcosmos.store.
Almost everything in the store is 10% off right
now and we have a limited edition Dark Mode Hydra
t-shirt that’s only available during the sale.
So check out microcosmos.store before August
8th if you want to get your hands on one.
All the people's whose names are coming up on the
screen right now, they are our patrons on Patreon.
They are the reason that we are able
to continue exploring this beautiful
unseen world that surrounds us. There
is so much left to explore and I am so
excited to continue exploring it
with you and all of our patrons.
And if you would like to become one of these
people you can go to Patreon.com/JounryToMicro.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
and why wouldn't you? You can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram or on TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us, there is
always a subscribe button, somewhere nearby.